Julia just catch us up to speed have i
got that right that we're going to see
now rousseff decide to appeal or
possibly that she could leave that leave
that appeal and accept the impeachment
from what we've heard so far she is
going to appeal that's what her lawyer
said yesterday she herself said
something similar when she was in
Congress on Monday she said the only
reason I have an appeal is because we
haven't you haven't voted yet so it's
very likely she does appeal to the
Supreme Court as she has throughout the
process I'm looking at the country guide
here and you can see that with any
country really but if you type up cou
and space BR on the Bloomberg you can
pull up all of the assets that have been
so strong Julia is it interesting to you
to see Brazil do so well with investors
and we're looking at what a six quarter
recession here interest rates of I think
14 and a quarter percent inflation it
must be very difficult for citizens to
understand this i qotta me it's the
economy hasn't rebounded yet it's very
hard to find signs some confidence
indicators have improved in the past
couple of months but you're right the
economy is still not doing well GDP came
in this morning a little bit below
expectations still negative so and the
markets have been rallying for months
and months based on this hope of
political change and some investors say
it got ahead of itself because now we
actually have to see any of this getting
done how much longer then what's the
time frame we're looking at for this
carrying on Julia because as you say
we've got an appeal as far as we know
how much longer do investors have all
this still some uncertainty the hope and
what investors are pushing for is that
timid will start acting a little bit
more forcefully and quickly now that
he's no longer the interim president he
doesn't really have that excuse that he
doesn't have this legitimacy he now
becomes the president until 2018 as you
said so he really has to push a little
harder for these reforms and these
fiscal adjustments that Brazil needs to
the economy out of the recession